- When you tell people that
I run a slot car they go,
"What, what's that?
I never heard of that before."
When they first do it they
go, "Wow, this is fun!"
I am "Buzz" Frank Perri.
I am the proprietor of Buzz-A-Rama,
the slot car racing center of the world.
On your marks,
get set,
go!
Slot car racing is a hobby sport
that's participated in all over the world.
In 1965, it was my hobby.
I was one of the first
to open in New York.
There was 48 places like this in the city.
Today, I'm it.
I'm the lone survivor.
They have 12 OTC motors in them
and a guide flag that fits in the slot
and when you hand control it,
it energizes those lanes
and gives the motor juice.
The fastest cars can go
upwards of 100 miles an hour.
So, they're like blurs now.
You have to hear them.
You go, "Weeng, weeng."
You can hardly see them,
you have to listen to them.
You go, "Wssh, wow!"
Kids play with computer now
and there's no interaction with anyone.
Over here they have
interaction with other drivers,
they compete,
they congratulate each other,
you learn sportsmanship.
It's really great.
Just watching the cars
go around the tracks
pumps up your adrenaline
and you get all excited
and that thrill never leaves you.
You always think about it.